time now for pft on yahoo sports peter
king and mike florio all the biggest
news in the national football league and
one of the most depressing realities of
the current nfl is the nfc east where
every team through 11 weeks peter has
three
wins and one of those teams is going to
realize boring a tie on thanksgiving a
doubling of their win total in five days
because both washington and dallas won
on sunday they meet on thanksgiving how
bad though is this division overall
well the the strange thing mike is that
sometimes you watch
a a single game by these teams you know
like you watch dallas at minnesota and
you say
not a bad team
you've watched washington several times
this year and he said boy that's a
pretty good team if they get even
b-minus quarterback play and right now
with alex smith
they're getting b
quarterback play basically
um and then the giants
you know the giants are such a different
team than they were six weeks ago and i
think if daniel jones
continues on the path of not turning it
over
starting this week against cincinnati
i might pick the giants in this division
i really might uh but i think the
biggest issue
that this division has right now is that
you know
i i don't see how i don't see how
philadelphia wins schedule is too hard
the next three weeks how are they going
to win even one of those the next three
weeks
but beyond that
you know
you have to look at the team that's on
the rise and right now to me it's the
new york giants the giants are on the
rise and unless dallas
continues
uh
you know to play if if andy dalton stays
healthy they continue to play that will
be the biggest threat to the new york
giants i would pick the giants to win
that division right now
i feel like whoever wins on thursday
though is going to have a shine it may
not last but think of that spot there's
going to be 30 million people who watch
because what the hell else are we going
to do at four o'clock eastern on
thursday afternoon but if the cowboys
win even if washington wins you know it
always feels like a big moment it feels
like a big spot and that team's gonna be
four and seven and and i don't disagree
with you that the giants have shown the
most promise lately
i really wonder though how much of what
happened last week between joe judge and
former offensive line coach mark columbo
given that offensive coordinator jason
garrett brought colombo to town how much
of that
that continues to echo maybe and
possibly affect the relationship between
judge and garrett since garrett was the
one who thought colombo was the answer
and columbo and judge had issues for
weeks
i think that's a great great question
we'll find out this week everybody's
going to talk nice everybody's going to
say hey we got to do what's best for the
team
but beneath the very neat pr spinach
uh part of this
you know we're going to see whether
first of all that offensive line was
playing a lot better
i mean a lot better and and so to make a
change now mike there's something about
this that just doesn't smell right
you know to make this decision now when
that unit is playing competently to good
right now and then to to blow it up
and to bring a guy in mike
i mean look i don't know dave to googly
elmo
but three of the last seven years
september 1 has come by and he's
unemployed
so how great a coach is he really
whatever the reason why he's unemployed
he's unemployed
and now he's the guy you're picking
rather than a guy the offensive line was
totally behind i i it's just this is
weird and i just look i trust joe judge
he's done a good job so far
this just doesn't pass the sniff test
really strange situation ugly incident
last week between judge and colombo
colombo based upon the reports crossed
the line with the term that he used
toward judge and that was that and now
they have to go forward but that could
be the one thing that ultimately keeps
the giants from winning the worst
division in football that's it for now
he's peter king i'm mike florio this is
pft on yahoo sports see you next tuesday
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports